the following program is paid content
for finish
fresh water
we can't live without it but it's
running out
fast we call this the bathtub ring and
the reservoir
has dropped 120 feet in the last
20 years
now i'm tracking down innovators who are
trying to turn the tide
we're here in the trenches right in a
desperate fight
to change our water thirsty ways laser
leveling our field helps us be very
efficient with our irrigation
but we can't just rely on the experts to
bring us back from the brink
and wait until after the water is
already down the drain
we all need to make changes in our daily
lives
[Music]
can we strike a balance between the
comforts of modern life
and the health of the planet
can we hang on to the fresh water we so
desperately need
[Music]
before we use up the last drop
los angeles california this is a city i
am very familiar with
a sprawling urban jungle home to more
than 10 million people
who together use almost one and a half
billion gallons of water
every day two decades of drought have
made the supply of fresh water
critically low
water shortages are happening all over
the world
agriculture and industry waste way too
much water
there are ever more people on the planet
and the weather is getting hotter
and drier
we have to do something if not for
ourselves
for the generations to come if you want
to make a change in the world
sometimes the best place to start is
right here at home
just imagine all the water across los
angeles wasted on lawns that no one
ever even uses i want to see
just exactly how i should adjust my life
even in the smallest ways
so i can stop being a part of the water
scarcity problem
start being part of the solution here to
help me is christa guerrero
from the metropolitan water district of
southern california
first she checks if all the faucets
toilets and shower heads in the house
are fitted with water-saving devices
then it's time for her to put my habits
under the microscope uh-oh
so how often would you say you run your
dishwasher so i like to do my dishes
but um i use the dishwasher when usually
i have a lot of guests
and do you rinse your dishes before you
put them in the dishwasher
uh yes i do i feel like that's the wrong
answer
you actually use less water when you use
a dishwasher than you do when you wash
by hand
the new ones are about three and a half
gallons
every time you run them that's like so
little and they still have the
high pressure that you would want in
order to not have to rinse your dishes
beforehand
got it thank you absolutely
how many showers would you say you take
a week seven
and do you know about how long you
shower for
um a few minutes probably
[Music]
you just want to get in get it done and
then you know get the coffee
do you know if the shower head is low
flow i don't believe so
an average shower length for most
americans is about 8 to 10 minutes long
and that's about 20 gallons of water for
that entire shower oh okay
and how often do you run your sprinklers
they're on a timer
okay the sprinklers that you have each
sprinkler nozzle puts out about the same
amount of water as an average american
shower
so if you think about having 20
sprinklers in your yard
that all go off at once you're so much
shame right now your lawn is taking 20
showers at once
so this is the process in which i'm
facing my demons
and we're going to make make things
better right
okay so the calculations that i have
your indoor water use is about 83
gallons per day
the average american is about 88.
so not too bad all right your outdoor
is at about 213 gallons per day
and that's mostly because of your
sprinkler system the average there is
about 112.
oh for most americans sorry
and so that brings you to a total of
about 296 gallons per day that you're
using
and around your home my daily water use
is much worse than i expected
especially in the yard it's time for me
to make some changes at home
averting a water crisis requires changes
outside the home too
agriculture manufacturing energy
these are all massive consumers of water
i'm shannon switzer swanson
a national geographic explorer and
marine social ecologist
my work takes me all around the world to
study how fishing communities
deal with environmental challenges like
pollution and climate change
but now i'm investigating a major
ecosystem that's under threat
right on my own doorstep the san
francisco bay
i'm heading out into the bay with john
rosenfield
he's the senior scientist with the
non-profit organization
san francisco bay keeper we're the
watchdogs of the bay the
the little boat that could uh we use
drones
and airplanes to monitor the largest
polluters bring them into court if we
need to
so john tell me what's going on in the
bay here well we're
witnessing an ecosystem collapse really
san francisco bay is home to six
species that are officially endangered
including
two unique forms of chinook salmon
and two kinds of smelt the orca whales
are also endangered
because they cannot get enough food and
they specialize on chinook salmon
so is that because of pollution caused
by people that's wrong that's running
into the bay
and the delta pollution is part of the
problem but there's really a bigger
problem
what we take out of the bay before it
reaches the bay
is fresh water we take that out
of the rivers that flow into the bay it
gets diverted to agriculture
and to urban uses how much fresh water
are we taking out of the bay
in a typical year we take out 50 of the
water
that would flow into the bay before it
reaches the bay
and in some years we take out as much as
70
on today's patrol we meet up with a fish
research vessel from the university of
california
davis i'm excited to see what they
caught
what are you catching it's a really nice
halibut oh my gosh
how amazing beautiful are you catching
any long pin smells
no longer smell to date okay and this
would be their habitat this is
definitely their habitat and
we're trying to understand why their
abundances are so low and whether
there's anything we can do to help
save the population
nowadays because we divert so much water
upstream
this is salt water perpetually
throughout the year in the winter
and spring normally this water that
we're on top of would be
fresh you could drink it does that
really make a huge difference to the
health of the ecosystem
it makes all the difference to an
estuary so it's really the mixing of
fresh water with salt water from the
ocean
that creates this nursery habitat that
the fish depend on
are we taking fresh water out to a level
that
isn't gonna work for much longer it's
definitely not sustainable i mean the
evidence is really clear
wow yeah i really had no idea how many
ways
freshwater affects the marine
environment as well
as a marine social ecologist what's
happening to the bay
is really troubling to me but also as
someone
who wants to start a family in
california it's critical for me to know
if there's a way to address this water
crisis
i just found out that i'm expecting a
baby
that gives me a brand new perspective on
living in a state that's partly desert
so i'm heading out to the american
southwest
to explore where our water comes from
and whether we can save enough of it
does it make sense to put down roots in
a place where the water may be about to
run out
from florida to new york to california
fresh water supplies are running
critically low
as a un goodwill ambassador on the
environment i'm passionate about
protecting ecosystems around the globe
[Music]
and now that i know just how much water
i'm wasting around the house
i'm making some changes in my daily
habits
not rinsing the dishes before they go
into the dishwasher is a no-brainer
and there are a few simple fixes that
i've been meaning to do for a long time
okay by changing from a toilet model
that uses 1.6 gallons per flush
to 1.2 gallons i can save up to 2
gallons a day
in the shower you can add a flow reducer
to the shower head
for an eight-minute shower this would
save up to 10 gallons of water per day
in the kitchen an aerator does a similar
job
reducing the flow by two and a half
gallons per minute
wouldn't tell the difference and i've
started collecting the water that
usually just
runs down the drain every day while i
wait for the shower to heat up
so i'm setting myself a personal goal at
home to cut my water consumption by 30
if everybody in the united states did
that we'd save eight and a half
billion billion with a b gallons of
water every single day
that's more water than flows through the
grand canyon each day
so what do you say want to save a river
the first stop on my journey through the
american southwest
is the mighty colorado river
it's the number one renewable water
resource for nevada
arizona and southern california
here on the nevada arizona border the
steep rock walls of this canyon created
the perfect site for building what was
at the time
the largest concrete structure in the
world
the hoover dam
[Music]
i've come here to meet john fleck a
professor of water policy at the
university of new mexico
to find out how much longer this river
can sustain us
every time i come to hoover dam i'm
struck by
how important this place is in the
growth of the western united states
it's the water supply for 40 million
people 5 million acres of farmland
the lettuce you eat all winter the
alfalfa that feeds the cows that make
your burgers and your pizza cheese
so much depends on this river and hoover
dam
is at the heart of the system it's the
dam that we built that made
all of that possible wow 40 million
people is a lot of people and i keep
hearing that we're running out of water
and
is that true yeah so we're not exactly
running out of water but we're headed in
that direction
because we're taking more water out of
the river and nature puts back in every
year
from its headwaters and the rocky
mountains the colorado river
snakes its way 1450 miles
down towards the gulf of california
on route more than a dozen dams
reservoirs and some of the longest water
canals
in the world serve seven states in the
u.s
and two in mexico
but a long and severe drought has put
this entire system under stress
it's been going on for almost 20 years
is that right 20 years of dry flow on
the colorado river among the driest
20-year periods like this
you know maybe in 500 or a thousand
years wow so that's a really long time
it
is there any thought about whether or
not we will get back to
normal again or is this just a new
normal the climate is getting drier
as greenhouse gases rise and earth's
temperature rises
we're seeing more evaporation and we
should not expect it to just bounce back
at some point
that's a bit scary it is a little
unnerving yeah
looking at the river here touching it
even
doesn't give me the sense that the
colorado is in jeopardy
but when john takes me to see the
reservoir on the other side of the dam
the depth of the crisis hits home
we call this the bathtub ring it's
minerals left behind as the lake drops
and that shows the lake has dropped 120
feet in the last
20 years why is that happening less
water coming in from upstream more water
going out downstream because we're using
it for our farms in
our cities you know you can stand here
and see
get this visceral feeling of how much
water is gone
the largest reservoir in the u.s is half
empty another couple hundred feet is
what we call deadpool
when you just can't get water out of the
lake anymore and that would be an
absolute disaster for millions of people
downstream
that is a calamity that we cannot afford
to let happen
and that's sort of what i'm dedicating
my life to is trying to help us
work through these problems the colorado
river's water supply
is critically low
[Music]
and just down the road is a fast-growing
desert city
famed for its culture of excess
las vegas
i'm here trying to understand something
that's really puzzling me
with over 42 million tourists every year
how does this city stay hydrated during
a mega drought
former water manager for southern nevada
pat mulroy
may have some answers not many people
have had to face water scarcity
on the scale that she has so pat you've
managed las vegas water for
about 25 years that's a very long time
and as it's grown then
have those challenges changed over the
years when i came here in 1974
none of this was here it was truly a
weekend gambling town
it was in the early 90s that the little
weekend gambling town started to
reinvent itself
as a full-scale metropolis
we were going through the first big
growth bubble and we were seeing water
increase
uses of 17 annually
which was pretty daunting
and then in 2002 the drought hit
it was one of the driest years on record
pat remembers the morning her deputy
broke the bad news
when she came in and said we've got
problems
we had huge problems there had been
virtually
zip snowpack in the upper basin so
obviously
conservation was the bedrock we sat down
with all the communities in southern
nevada
and had to change their building codes
landscaping codes
everything a new home could only have
a quarter of their backyard grass the
front yard could have
no grass whatsoever and we were paying
people to start ripping grass out
by the time 2004 hit we had cut our use
by
a third it was phenomenal that is also
very impressive that you were able to
bring all these different
conservation efforts together and people
together we didn't have time to fight
you know failure was not an option this
whole community would have disappeared
it seems to me that managing this
unpredictability requires an
extra level of resourcefulness and on a
tour of the resort's golf course
i'm intrigued to find out why this one
hasn't been torn out
like most of the others you're on
probably the oldest
golf course in southern nevada that goes
back to the 40s
and it is been transformed
through applying technology with soil
sensors and
weather stations it uses only as much
water as it
absolutely has to have at the right time
and every drop has been recycled
so when you say i can combine
a really water efficient historic
open space with the state-of-the-art
technology to where it uses absolutely
the least amount of water possible
to me that's a success story
30 years from now two-thirds of the
world's population
is expected to live in a city and as our
cities get bigger and thirstier it won't
just be desert cities like vegas taking
drastic measures
like ripping up lawns i'm on my way to
arizona
one of the hottest states in the u.s
the innovators who are finding ways to
thrive in this desert
could be the pioneers our dry planet so
badly needs
[Music]
in the average california home most of
the water use isn't in the house
it's in the yard and this house is no
different
it's time i did something about that
this is your blank slate i love a blank
slate
i've enlisted the help of jackie serber
an expert in sustainable gardening
there's a lot of existing elements that
i think are good for conservation
these pipes are connected to a system
that bring the water off the roof
and water this area which i think is
good it is good that it's back here but
when you have
a lot of water coming out of a small
pipe onto just bare soil
that's a situation where runoff can
start to occur and
erosion so we want to find a way to slow
that water down and sink it into the
soil
so by the time we're done transforming
it with
compost mulch we're going to build a
swale a rain garden
so when you have a rain storm and
there's a surge of water
we're creating a place for that water to
go and then over time it will slowly
permeate into the soil and the plants
around it are going to
take up that water can i help yes if you
can dig
i actually my favorite thing to do okay
great put me to work
we will jackie's design features native
plants that not only need very
little water they also support local
populations of insects
and birds bonus by remodeling this yard
i'm going to be reducing my water
footprint
by a lot and yards are where homes use
the most water
and i'll be capturing rainwater where it
falls
that rain water nourishes tree roots and
ultimately replenishes aquifers
very deep underground i feel really good
doing my
tiny part directing groundwater back
into the aquifer
these underground layers of porous rock
store vast volumes of ancient rainwater
but all across the u.s cities farmers
and industry
are extracting this vital water
reservoir far faster than nature can
replenish it
about 30 of the water once stored
beneath kansas is already gone
some freshwater springs in florida now
produce less than half the flow
they used to climate change appears to
be making droughts
longer and drier
there you go so i want to do everything
i can to conserve water
okay so this 60 gallon barrel will
fill up in one day of heavy rain it's a
gift from the sky
can't wait for it to rain now
tracking rainfall over time is essential
to
understanding drought patterns but with
something as infrequent as a mega
drought
how do you know what's normal i'm
heading south
east from vegas toward tucson to meet a
special kind of meteorologist
not one who looks at radar and
satellites
but one who looks at ancient trees
connie woodhouse from the university of
arizona
is taking me to mount lemmon just north
of tucson to collect some tree ring
samples
we're looking for the oldest tree that
we can core because the oldest trees are
going to give us
the most information and then once the
threads engage
it's just a matter of turning it all
right
and this doesn't hurt the tree it's kind
of like
getting a shot you know the whole will
fill what's up it's a healing
and we want to get the spoon upright and
then we'll
pull it out there it is
so there's the core
connie's tree ring research lab contains
half a million tree samples
okay so here's what the core looks like
after it's sanded down so you can see
it's much clearer
yeah that's really beautiful yeah here's
the bark again can you show me the dry
and the wet ears on here
um these little rings here the 1930s
drought
here's the 1950s trout is it tiny
because it's a
from a drought year yeah it's tiny
because it's super super dry
but the crown jewel in connie's
collection comes from a tree that
started growing
900 years ago all right so here's a
piece of the colorado river actually
this
site uh trail gulch is is right in the
headwaters
this is pinyon pine um the inside date
on this tree so
about when it started growing was in the
1100s
do you think that these droughts that
you're seeing in the past
are any different from this drought
we're currently seeing based on the
record
of tree rings from the colorado river
you know 20 years of drought is a pretty
long drill
however if we go back to the 1100s we
see a drought that's
about six decades and so that's really
quite a bit longer than what we've seen
at least to date in the recent drought
the drought in the west is already
having dramatic effects
in california with some rivers running
dry
industry and agriculture have been
drawing billions of gallons of water a
year from underground aquifers
so much that nasa satellites have
detected the ground sinking
by up to two feet a year and cutting
back on this water usage
is a huge challenge because most of the
time
we don't even know we're using it
i'm working on trimming my daily water
use by around 100 gallons that's great
but i recently heard a shocking
statistic
every pound of beef we eat takes 1800
gallons of water to produce
so the most water-saving action we can
take is cutting down on meat
[Music]
but getting people to do that can be
really hard
so i'm going to make it a little easier
i'm taking a trip across town to meet
chef babette davis
owner of stuff i eat in inglewood
she's been preparing vegan delights for
the last 30 years
voila her food is so hard to resist
you started with dessert and you started
without
me you put yum in front of me i'm gonna
have some come on
hmm okay so what do we got here so right
here you've got a little faro
you've got black beans enchilada pie you
like it it's
amazing are you kidding me i'm from new
mexico oh okay
this is very similar is it yeah to what
my mom
used to rock we call it enchilada pie
how long have you been
vegan since 1990.
i was turning 40. i'll be 70 in december
get out of here
no oh are you serious
i can still do a four-minute plank i
don't think i could do a four minute
plane
probably can't boom
[Laughter]
it's the best thing i ever did we've got
to do something
because the planet can't sustain itself
with the way that we're behaving cattle
farming
is responsible for about 90 percent
of the amazon deforestation 90
that's ridiculous these light green
patches are farms that have been
clear-cut into the amazon
to raise cows or to grow soy to feed
pigs in asia every cow
and every pig eats tons of feed in its
lifetime
so when you eat meat you indirectly
guzzle
all the water it took to grow all these
crops
a lot of people are saying that um
eating sustainably or being
an environmentalist is a privilege is
that true
sweetheart they sell organic produce at
the 99 cent stores
it don't cost you much to cook up some
beans
it depends on where your head is where
your heart is and what you want to do
i introduced this concept called
hefetarianism
where you cut your meat consumption by
half so every other day
you eat plant-based it's easier and you
know arguably
anybody could do it i'm humbled now to
be here eating with you and you know
what i'm so happy to have you
now i have literally ingested your
wisdom thank you
and it is tasty i have to say really
really good
that's wonderful i love you for this
by 2050 we're going to produce half a
billion tons of animal meat a year
at 1800 gallons of water per pound of
beef
that's an enormous waste of water if you
really
look at yourself in the mirror and
you're honest i i think it's
hard to deny that it's time to at least
make somewhat of a change towards a
vegan lifestyle
[Music]
livestock farmers in the amazon don't
have to worry about where their water
comes from
but in arizona the largest reliable
influx of water
has to be pumped uphill from the
colorado river
the central arizona project is a 336
mile canal
which delivers water to phoenix and
tucson and to most of the farms between
[Music]
as i drive through this parched land i
expect the farmland around me to be
growing low water
desert desert-friendly crops but what i
mostly see
is arizona's biggest agricultural export
cotton a notoriously water-hungry crop
to find out why i've come to tucson to
meet brian wong
a third generation arizona farmer
my grandfather planted his first crop
back in 1939
so that's what 81 years ago
yes one of his first crops was cotton
and
it really wasn't native to the region
back in the late 30s but
growing here in a hot and dry climate
actually
allows cotton to thrive a lot more
because you don't have a whole lot of
bugs since it's kind of too hot for them
to live
so how is all of this water actually
getting to your farm for you to use yeah
so we actually have
seven different uh pump stations on the
cap canals
so you know you hear the noise in the
background that's actually our pumps
running
we apply the water right out of the
ditch into the field
and then it you know evenly moves across
the field and irrigates efficiently
the way we achieve that is laser
leveling our fields and even
doing laser leveling in between crops so
that helps us be
very efficient with our irrigation
but the current 20-year drought forced
brian to rethink his family's
traditional cotton
he began looking for less thirsty more
desert hardened species
one of our very first grains that we
started with was called white sonora
wheat
a lot of the native american tribe south
of here used to grow white sonora wheat
but in the early 1900s that was kind of
pushed out by the more modern grain
varieties
so you know we're one of the major
producers of white sonora wheat
and you know we're very happy to bring
it back to this area
brian's switch to a traditional desert
crop has helped him cut his water use
nearly in half compared with his
grandfather's cotton farm
[Music]
some steam and his grain has found an
enthusiastic local market artisanal
baker
don guerra often makes themselves a
thousand loaves in three hours
cheers cheers customers of barrio bread
often tell him his loaves remind them of
the bread they used to eat
decades ago that is so delicious oh my
goodness
when you realize that it can take more
than 700 gallons of water to grow the
cotton for just one t-shirt
it really doesn't make a lot of sense to
grow cotton out here in the desert
that's why what brian is doing is so
impressive in the face of a punishing
drought he's managed to grow less
thirsty crops
and he's been a huge success he's truly
inspirational
growing cotton is water intensive and
the production process of making clothes
out of it uses
even more but i just can't live without
my genes
i was told that you have some genes that
use a lot less water to make cool yeah
so that's going to be our sea gene
okay these guys yeah so these are made
out of 100 organic cottons
and they use about 130 gallons per pair
of jeans
they also happen to feel really good if
there's any rips or tears or anything
bring them back in and we'll patch them
up and get them all fixed for you so you
extend the life of them zach
that's great yeah reduce on the waste
exactly awesome cool
you know we shouldn't underestimate as
consumers we have a lot of purchasing
power and we can vote with our dollars
did you know that it takes 3 000 gallons
of water
to make a smartphone that's why i
haven't upgraded mine in
five years or so so if you want to save
water
i think we just have to kick the habit
of constant
consumption but getting a grip on water
is not just about using less of it
it's about putting back the water we've
been over extracting from the ground for
decades
can we turn a desert into a sustainable
oasis
[Music]
phoenix arizona the hottest city
in the u.s that gets only eight inches
of rain a year
[Music]
this place was built by draining
trillions of gallons of ancient water
stored in aquifers deep below it
but i'm here to meet someone who's
turning this idea on its head
a woman who has helped to create a
miraculous oasis
in the sonoran desert catherine sorensen
was phoenix's director of water
management
for seven years
we wanted to show you the tres rios
wetlands that basically
polishes our reclaimed water after it
leaves the
wastewater treatment plant it creates
this amazing wetland
that is home to dozens of different
species of animals and birds
if you told me this was water from a
sewage plant
i absolutely would not believe you you
know the technology is really
um very advanced uh we clean the water
to very high standards and then of
course mother nature does her bit
basically you can think of a wastewater
treatment plant as a big iron stomach it
works essentially the same way
there's bugs and bacteria that break
down the
liquids and the solids the liquids we
then further treat
and filter and reclaim and then we
deliver them here to the wetlands before
this was a wetland what was here
just desert um and it's taken us
really decades to create this and build
it to what it is today
and is that helpful for for replenishing
the aquifers it is there's infiltration
to the aquifers through the riverbed
and the surrounding area and that's
important too because we really want to
manage our groundwater for the very long
term
phoenix used to be very dependent on
groundwater supplies and we were
basically draining the aquifer which is
obviously
not a good water management strategy the
ability for phoenix to survive
over the very long term is really
entirely dependent on how well we manage
our aquifers
over the past two decades phoenix has
worked hard to replenish its depleted
aquifers
not just with reclaimed water but by
banking extra colorado river water
delivered by the cap canal
it now has enough supply to last for
years even if the rivers were to run dry
we're here in the trenches right this is
a desert city
and you can't go through a summer here
without understanding that water here is
really a life or death
issue i think this is a good example of
how you can meet those challenges
and leverage mother nature while you're
doing it
these wetlands remind me that smart
water management is not just about using
less
it's also about maintaining the massive
stores of fresh water
beneath our feet
every homeowner can join this effort too
i can collect the water
uh into a pipe and direct it to the
tanks over there
in my yard project the job is in the
hands of landscape designer jackie
serber and landscape contractor salvador
razo
perfect and so then on top of the tanks
we'll install
some gravel and then fabric to keep the
soil from getting into the tanks that's
correct
they're working to make the most of
water that falls from the sky
wow this is really coming along walk me
through it what's going on here yes so
it's coming together this is the uh
beginnings of
our swale and our rain garden here there
were two downspouts coming off of the
roof
and all the hard surfaces around the
property
one of those we've redirected to the
swale here which is this kind of
ditch and one is going into the
infiltration pane right
can we check it out yes okay salvador
how's it going
do you want to give adrian a little
explanation here
um what we're doing it's uh collecting
the water that comes from the roof
that's why we did this uh infiltration
tank you can see
salvador's adding gravel the fabric is a
barrier between the soil and the gravel
so we're basically trying to maintain
the voids
so that it can fill with water in a
heavy downpour
in the event for some reason this tank
fills all the way up
this little pop-up device will pop up
and then it will flow through the garden
naturally yes through the mulch so this
is just a great way to get a surge of
water into the soil
and then it can soak in and all these
trees can take it out right surge and
soak
and it looks beautiful which is i mean
i i was not expecting it to be as
gorgeous yeah we just we want this
garden to put a smile on everyone's face
that comes through bring in the habitat
and everything for you to enjoy for
years to come and i would argue that
happiness
is sustainable
it gives me hope that even a city like
los angeles
long a symbol of humanity's conquest of
nature and concrete and steel
can get back into balance with the local
ecosystems
but it starts with water and with each
one of us changing the way we think
about it
after traveling through the desert
states of nevada and arizona
following the life-giving water of the
colorado river
i'm back home in the bay area a home
where i'll soon be raising a child
and needing to nurture that new life
with clean
fresh water so i'm encouraged to see
drought tolerant yards
appearing all over my neighborhood
my local library has cut its potable
water use by 90 percent and it looks
stunning
[Music]
drought tolerant yards don't just save
water they protect fragile ecosystems
like the san francisco bay from polluted
runoff
live next to this incredible beauty
and to know that it can be preserved if
we all work together
makes me feel like this is a good place
to put down roots
we need to spend more time out here it's
beautiful so gorgeous
every person i met on my journey is
doing their part to turn the tide on
their water crisis
whether it's cutting water use on one
farm
or for a whole city and for all these
people it just started with a change in
their mindset
and that gives me hope for the future
and it's why i feel good about starting
a family here in california
we'll be another family that truly
appreciates the value of water and we'll
be here
to spread that new way of thinking about
water
[Music]
ah look at this i mean
looks done yes it's pretty much done
this is the completed rain garden uh
this is the meadow that we talked about
using the meadow grasses that
are very low in water needs and they
will
get fed by all the runoff from the rain
garden
so water comes from the roof down
through the beds fills up and then gets
soaked in
exactly so the idea is that the water's
sinking in and it's spreading out and so
all these plant roots are able to take
up that water
and it's staying in the backyard not
going exactly all the water that falls
here is staying here
and uh one more thing we'd love to show
you
if you follow me we got a little
surprise surprise
okay do you have any idea what this is
not exactly but i have a feeling it has
something to do with conserving water
yes this is a very cool regenerative
guarding technique called
hugel culture hugo culture
yes it means mound culture in german
and it's basically a swale using
a lot of logs that you had lying around
and so the idea is
these logs are becoming spongy and
they're breaking down and they're
turning into
soil it's all very underneath that you
can see
um now it's just coated with the plants
it was like a sponge
correct so we have herbs we've brought
some strawberries for you to plant
yeah for me to plant yes i'd be honored
[Music]
alrighty
voila i am so
absolutely grateful for you two and for
your whole team
for coming in here and making this
ignored and abandoned
wasteland into something useful and
beautiful look how gorgeous this is
we just really hope that everybody that
sees this and sees these gardens is
inspired to do something in their own
home
and slowly but surely one garden at a
time we can really change
the way water is used in landscaping
when i first met christa guerrero from
the metropolitan water district
i was shocked to discover how much water
i've been wasting
even on small things like rinsing my
dishes
so i set myself a challenge to reduce my
indoor and outdoor water use by 30
so now is the moment of truth we'll see
how i did
so i hear you've been busy what changes
have you made yes
a couple things i did i changed the
toilet from a 1.6
to a 1.2 gallon toilet excellent
installed water efficient
kitchen faucet that's great i installed
low flow shower head
and i stopped rinsing the dishes before
i put them in the dishwasher they're
just such a good one
i installed a rain garden oh i didn't
personally i helped a little bit
we have an efficient mp rotator
irrigation system
nice swallowing rain barrel which is
pretty cool so
i did good you did great you want your
total number
for the whole house give it to me okay
so you remember you about
just under 300 gallons per day
originally
you came all the way down to 136 gallons
per day
that's a 55 reduction in your water use
and again it was appliances and small
changes around the house you didn't do
anything
did it feel drastic no it was no sweat
at all
excellent see so you can absolutely
start to put in a little sweat and see
how low you can go
guys come on join me let's do this
simple choices
it's easy to assume there's plenty of
water to grow food
to drink and to live our lives with
but less than two percent of the
planet's water is clean accessible fresh
water
this program has paid content for finish
there's enough water on earth to sustain
us but only if we
use it right and don't abuse it
we need to start thinking about our
relationship to water in everything we
do
before we get down to the last drop
you